Sweden is moving in the market economic
direction but that does not mean that
the United States should be moving in
the socialist direction I've written a
book called den capitalist is caberta
Sultan which means the capitalist
welfare state that is basically an
attempt to explain the puzzle of Sweden
to an international audience income
taxes in Sweden are extremely high by us
standards there's no arguing if you
increase your income you get to keep 60%
for yourself and you lose 40% to the
government and if you're rich you get to
keep 45% for yourself and you lose fifty
five to the government basically what
sets Sweden apart from other countries
is the high degree of transfers and that
means basically the government keeps
your money and hands them out to you
again later in life they take care of
pensions they take care of sickness
insurance unemployment insurance
you also get basic education for free
actually up to a PhD all universities
are free as well health care heavily
subsidised you get childcare also
heavily subsidised and it is not the
case that people are taxed at very high
levels and then those taxes are used to
give to someone else
actually eighty eighty-five percent of
the taxes you pay or return to you as an
individual so even high income earners
and the upper middle class have an
incentive to support the welfare state
because it takes care of the insurance
for them as well the amount that is
transferred to the very poorest is
actually very small in Sweden Sweden is
probably more efficient than most other
countries and that is probably the
reason that people accept such a big
government I've had some personal
experience with the US public sector it
seems terribly inefficient and I can
and not wanting it to grow Sweden does
not prove that socialized healthcare
works I would say rather the opposite
the healthcare part of the Swedish
public sector is where many of the
problems are the health care system is
politically planned they've decided that
that prices should be zero or close to
zero this of course means that demand is
much higher than supply and this of
course leads to huge waiting times and
and it is not possible to pay more to be
able to get access faster that's not the
way the Swedish system works so even
very routine surgery you might have to
wait for months and years because before
you get access to it some people seek
health care outside of Sweden in order
to cut waiting time for example and also
in order to improve quality of the care
that they want if we'd leave a healthy
life they eat healthy
they don't drink much they don't smoke
much and they don't eat crappy fatty
food which is the major reason for the
long life expectancy it is not that
Swedish health care is is super
efficient or highly successful in Sweden
the capital side is the reason why
Sweden is a rich country this basically
explains the tremendous growth that
Sweden had between 1870 and and 1970
when Sweden grew from being one of the
poorest countries in Europe to being the
fourth richest country in the world some
people feel that Sweden grew rich
because of social democracy or labour
unions or by the fact that we had
forests and or that we could export or
just by chance of not being involved in
World War one or a world war two this is
all true but that's not the reason
Sweden grew rich Sweden grew rich like
any country that is rich through
well-functioning capitalist institutions
work trade innovation for most of the
20th century Swedish enterprise could
make a case for the free market economy
but in the end of the 1960s they could
no longer defend the leftist ideology
that swept over the entire world and all
political parties in Sweden were
influenced by this so even the
right-wing parties started discussing
socializing part of the private
enterprise started raising taxes started
demanding a highly regulated labor
market and so on then you had a period
of 20 25 years when policy was bad and
the economy was lagging behind Sweden
that used to be the fourth richest
country in the world fell relative to
other countries interestingly there was
an increasing awareness that the
policies of the 1970 were not
functioning and that they were actually
the cause of the problems in Sweden so
during the 80s and and the early 1990s
reforms were implemented if you look at
growth rates
latest 1012 years Sweden has been doing
well actually been growing faster than
the average European country and some
people look at these growth figures and
and and claim that this is proof that
socialism is working but it is not this
is of course what you expect if you
deregulate and liberalize to the extent
that Sweden has actually done the most
important thing is is that you lower the
top marginal tax rates that used to be
around 80 percent it's still high tax
level but it's no longer very
progressive and that's a big change
taxes are high on labour and consumption
so that they can be low on corporations
and capital why well capital can easily
move to other countries corporations can
more easily move to other countries
there have been D regulations of
basically everything from taxi air
services railroads electricity
telecommunications and gules used to be
state-run state-owned and there was no
freedom of choice at all
so we now have free school choice and
competition in a way that I know for
sure would be radical in the States
you basically now are allowed to choose
any school you like that school will
still be tax funded but it can be run by
a corporation by the parents it can be
run by the local municipality and the
ones who decide if the school gets
funding or not or the parents and the
pupils because the more choose that's
cool the more funding it will get
[Music]
what strikes me is that the 25 or even
20 year period when policy was
completely lunatic mad gone berserk is
the period that has shaped the
reputation of Sweden if you compare
economic freedom in Sweden 1980 and 2000
you will find that it has increased in
all areas except for the fact that taxes
are still high should America be more
like Sweden I think is a strange
question to ask because it cannot be
more like Sweden you could increase
taxes up to Swedish levels but you will
spend them on an American public sector
and I would not advise that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]